[Music]
chuck yeah
we're gonna talk about hot potatoes
today oh god and i am hungry too
good
now i like mine
kind of uh baked with a little bit of
butter and sour cream
and maybe a little bit cheese
okay so here's my thing as do i however
what i find myself doing is putting so
much butter
in my mash in in the in the baked potato
and then i start mashing it inside there
i'm saying i really just want mashed
potatoes yes
what you did was you made a pocket
mashed potato that's really what i want
in life uh mashed potatoes that's right
i've resigned myself to that sounds
delicious so here's the thing
i'm going to this is a very simple
explainer video very simple okay
there's a measure
of how much energy it takes
to change the temperature of an object
or anything
one degree celsius
okay okay for water
that's one calorie
okay so one calorie of energy can raise
the temperature of one cubic centimeter
of water which is about one milliliter
one degree celsius now suppose you have
some substance that takes two calories
to do the same thing
so that takes more energy to raise the
same to the same amount of temperature
okay
and you can imagine that such
things exist all right
so
uh there's some substances
that take an enormous amount
of energy
to raise the temperature just one degree
celsius okay an enormous amount of
energy well it's just more than more
than usual okay
and
once more than usual like 10 calories to
raise it one degree celsius no no three
or you know two or three times that you
know less than one no there's some that
are very high and very low but in in in
the kitchen and in the kitchen it's just
factors of a few okay
all right now
uh so
a potato
has a high and we have a term for it's
called specific heat it is how much heat
does it take to raise
uh one uh gram of it one centimeter one
celsius degree all right okay so it's
called specific so potatoes have a high
specific heat what that means is
they take a long time to cook
okay right okay you can't put a if
you're baking and not microwaving you
can't just put a potato in there for
five minutes and then it's done
no that doesn't work unless you want to
break a tooth
it's in there for like 45 minutes an
hour an hour and a half okay
how about
making toast
okay
so you can have toast for breakfast
and you take a piece of toast put it in
the toaster
after how much time is the toast done
uh i would say 45 seconds me a minute
two minutes max okay
so 45 minutes versus two minutes so
toast has a very low specific heat it
doesn't take much energy to raise its
temperature
how much you want
okay
so
the only point of what i'm saying here
and i might not have 10 minutes to talk
about it
because it's well get it done sooner
unless you have some questions is
let's take the toast out of the toaster
all right okay
uh how long does it take before your
butter does not melt on it oh man three
seconds right that's my point okay
that's my point sucks the faster you
were able to heat it
the faster it's gonna cool down
right the related phenomenon that's kind
of cool to know took you 45 minutes to
an hour to bake your damn potato
you could pull the potato out leave it
on your plate come back 20 minutes later
it'll still melt your butter
true
unless of course you cut it open and
splay it all out and you let it in your
chocolate yeah but you that you're
purposefully making it but you you
cooked it as a as this oblong spheroid
you put it on your plate as an object
oblong spray it'll stay hot for a long
time that's why we talk about
hot potato instead of hot toast
well yes right it felt like a hot potato
and in fact i'm told
that people in the arctic i just heard
this i haven't verified it but it kind
of makes sense they would bake potatoes
in the oven
and then take those potatoes and fill up
their pockets with it before they went
out into the arctic cold
because it was a sustained source of
heat for them got heat
and lunch
that's awesome
that is awesome
that's right and you can start eating at
whatever is the right temperature for
you to eat it that's the same thing
so so it's it's highly correlated how
quickly something cools with how little
time it took you to get it up to
temperature in the first place
so
let's take an ice cube right right how
long does it take to make ice
in your freezer a little while it takes
a little longer
take a little while okay
you pull out the ice take it out uh put
it on like a on a
wooden cutting board which is not very
absorbent it'll stay ice for the next
half hour practically yeah yeah yeah
it'll slowly melt but there's there's
maybe a little bit of ice in there
so
uh and another thing how long does it
take you just to cool water
to your refrigerator temperature not too
long i mean it might take an hour
um
you pour out yourself a glass pull it
out and leave a glass of water on the
counter uh that'll that'll get to room
temperature pretty fast yeah you better
like warm water
if you're just gonna if you're gonna
pour it and leave it yeah so this is if
you want to think about your foods and
and if you're a master chef you want to
pull things out
such that everything is the right
temperature when you serve it yep but
but you don't have six ovens necessarily
right so you got to cook some things put
it on the back burner bring it in the
front and if you think this through and
the physics of how long it takes to heat
something
you can sharply
uh
prepare
you you could prepare different foods so
that they're all ready at exactly the
same time and they're warm when they
need to be
that's great i just remember the chef
that i worked for
when i was waiting tables i'm just so
glad that he didn't know that
because he was really mean
he was just a mean guy and i could just
see him screaming at the other chefs
just like what is wrong with you you
fizz you physics deficient homunculus
what is your problem do you not know
basically right basic physics that it
took
an hour to get this up to temperature
like oh man
but that is really that's kind of cool
though that's kind of cool because you
know what it's funny you say that
that is why you have to let your meat
rest
because it has to cool so that when you
cut it open
all the juices just don't fly up fall
out and you end up having a dry piece of
meat yeah so there are multiple reasons
for doing that with meat but once you
know the thermodynamics of the food
you're preparing it gives you a level of
power over your food that you would have
never previously had i like that yeah so
you don't want the food having power
over you that don't work no that's not
good no that's bad so that's all it's a
simple thing that's where you get the
expression hot potato and not hot toast
okay
that's all
okay
plus toast breaks and nobody nobody
wants to play that game
hot toast
there's toast for your pocket right yeah
it's from your pocket it's oh well i
snuggled with the slice of toast you
know snuggle with it i started off with
lunch i got bird food now basically
pigeon food so yeah
so that's all that's a quickie that's a
quick one yeah i like it so throw it out
there all right chuck this has been a
star talk explainer uh neil degrasse
tyson here
keep looking up
[Music]
you